if you're not a fan of spiders feast
your eyes on this it's a larva of
parasitic wasp sucking an arachnid dry
and it is simply put not a pleasant way
to go but that isn't even the weirdest
bit about this bizarre interaction the
spider builds two kinds of webs one it
uses for catching prey and another
that's simpler and less sticky as you
can see in this clearly not Hollywood
quality video it uses that web for when
it needs to molt it's not a great idea
to snag prey while the spiders shedding
its exoskeleton and waiting for a new
one to harden up after the wasp mom lays
her egg on the spider host the resulting
larvae starts to slowly suck the juices
out of it but the larva is also mind
controlling it to build a structure
similar to the minimalist web exactly
how the hell a parasite can do that
isn't yet clear once the web is finished
the larva sucks the life out of the
spider and then spins a cocoon for
itself because the web reflects UV light
it acts like a traffic cone protecting
it from birds which see UV light that
might crash into it and destroy the
larva while it's transforming into a
wasp and when it does the whole weird
circus starts anew